my name is Lauren Bruckner I invented
pull-to-refresh I worked at Apple on the
original iPhone I wrote a program called
tweety which was sold to Twitter and
became the Twitter client for the iPhone
I worked on a game called letterpress
and now I'm one of the creators of the
rag bounce project and can you tell me
what that is what the rug must protect
is the rag masked project is a set of
extremely simple extremely fast to
manufacture plans for face masks why did
you decide to do this we had a sewing
machine and I tried following a few of
the plans online and I'm not an
experienced sower by any stretch of the
imagination so we just developed
something that was much simpler to
create something that I could follow
like that was the design constraint
could I do it this was one of my first
sewing projects
I guess my philosophy is I can't think
about something without using my hands I
mean it's the same with programming it's
the same with fabric it's the same with
wood it's the same with anything so if I
can get some fabric in my hands and a
sewing machine and you basically just
like iterate over and over and over and
over again eventually good ideas will
fall out of it and this particular shape
of mask is just happens to be extremely
easy to make and it fits pretty well
it's not finished yet we have like two
or three more versions coming and I'm
thinking of it more as a technology
product rather than a garment we're
literally versioning it you know we're
up to version 2.2 2.3 is coming tonight
3.0 is coming next week and they're each
gonna be refined in some way do you have
one of the masks there by any chance I
do I have I don't have one of the ones
on the website now but I have one of the
ones that I'm working on we're trying to
make it even simpler to make straps we
can't find elastic everyone's out of
elastic you can't even buy it online
anymore so that's why we call it a rag
mash where literally you can make it out
of rags dish towels sheets old
pillowcases so this one we're telling
people it's not out yet but we basically
just put loops on the ends and then
people can take shoelaces or anything
else they have we're gonna deliver masks
without any straps at all and they're
gonna supply their own straps and it
saves us a lot of time in material can
anyone make these masks and what do you
need to make them really all you need is
a needle and thread
and some old fabric any fabric a few
people now hand stitch them it takes a
little bit longer if you have a sewing
machine it goes a lot faster you really
want to wear any kind of mask even if
you don't have a needle and thread there
there are tons of designs out there the
CDC just put one up you can fold up
anything with two rubber bands and put
it behind your ears and I mean that's
more effective than nothing how do you
know that these masks are effective a
lot of the benefit isn't necessarily the
filtration ability of the mask it's
because you're not filtering the virus
itself you're filtering out droplets
which are much much larger than the
virus but you're reducing the radius of
you know aerosol is coming out of your
mouth and infecting one another we
started the project before the CDC and
the World Health Organization were
recommending widespread masks use so at
this point we're relatively confident
that they're effective in some way on
the wider public perception of masks
wearing can you talk a bit about that
whether you think everyone should wear
them outside or not I feel like most of
the people watching this video probably
aren't wearing pants because everyone's
at home like no one can tell if I'm
wearing pants right now
but culturally if you do have to leave
the house which you should avoid you
would put on pants and I think the shift
that needs to happen is if you put on
your pants you should put on a mask and
if you're the only one wearing pants
it's not enough everyone else needs to
be wearing pants everyone else needs to
be wearing a mask
you should get weird looks if you're not
wearing a mask that's that's the way I
think about